hi there reject nation I'm Greg Alba I'm
John old Humphrey so Sony has finally
listened to our demands and is doing
what Sony does best releasing a lot of
footage from their upcoming spider-man
movie to set it in the last time we saw
a clip go check out that got three today
premiered on movieclips coming soon
channel I think that's where premiered I
don't know that's where I got it from
opera overtures the water rises
elemental exposition or an expositional
scene I think that one is the one I'm
most interested in so we'll save that
one for last we're just gonna watch all
three and then we're gonna talk about it
you know how we do let's start with
opera overtures lucky for us oh you got
the best seats in the house I love him
on curb I know the other guy on silicon
back there you mean listen to each other
yeah classic Peter Parker problems can't
balance his words his lovely he can't do
it haha let's watch the water rises now
sequels to the win rise
[Music]
Oh Parker
[Music]
ouch
[Music]
hugs great
there is
[Music]
good mix of cutting the practical
moments of the stunts and then the CGI
looks great there but hey we got one
more to check out exposition
this is mr. are you handled yourself out
there today so if you didn't tower
they were born in stable orbits within
black holes creatures formed from the
primary elements air water fire earth
the science division had a technical
name we just called them elementals
versions of them exists across our
mythology's turns out the myths are real
my Thor Laura was amazing my studying my
physics class threats they burst
materialized on my earth many years ago
I was part of the last battalion trying
to stop them all we did was delay the
inevitable
the elementals are here now attacking
the same coordinates our satellites
confirm it we have one mission killer
you're coming with us
yes if you're this all seems like a big
time cut you know huge superhero kind of
stuff spider-man sir it's please you've
been to space called him a [ __ ] it's
good it's good all right favorite moment
in the whole movie well let's talk about
these clips now shall we before we talk
directly about some of these clips the
thing that's gotten me most excited
about this upcoming movie because I sort
of thought we were walking into a bit of
an ant-man the wasp kind of situation in
terms of you get this heavy film like
infinity war and a couple months later
you get a man on the wasp which is
important to watch to keep up with a
whole canon same time it's a lot more
you know a lot of levity it's really
light eaters wait really
Iza fun again and then you get endgame
and I thought that's what we're gonna
get here where the stakes might not be
as intense it might not be as emotional
that's a lot of what I was the
impression I was getting from watching
the marketing recently Kevin Feige did
come out say that the Infinity Saga
technically does end with far from home
the perfect way to end it because you
know Tony Stark dies an endgame you know
that whoa spoilers yes sorry I didn't
say spoiler warning Russo brothers told
us to spoil it they said well is
spoiling he said that it ends here
because you know Ironman started off and
a lot of this is gonna deal with
grieving after
death of Ironman Peter was heavily
influenced and mentored by you know Tony
Stark so it makes sense the ended here
but then on top of that with the early
reactions a lot of them were praising
how so much of this film is a spoiler
you know I was thinking about homecoming
and I'm like yeah you can spoil a lot of
like details but specific to that movie
yeah but there's like a lot of plot
points they're not really big spoiler
stuff you know there's certain things
I'm like oh why they didn't ruin that
but for the most part it was a fun
Spider Man baby with a couple of cool
twists in there everyone with the
reactions to this latest one are saying
like the last half is extraordinary and
there's so many things you can spoil now
I'm like kind of stepping back from some
theories I've been making there's one
theory from this clip that I still think
is true Mysterio and must be lying his
ass off here's what I'm thinking is
going on because he explains the
elementals I still think this is part of
his whole illusion game I would imagine
like the best bet that I would theorize
Quinten is from another dimension is
from some other earth he's probably
enemies with spider-man over there I
don't know exactly what he's doing here
I feel like all these elemental things
are all just big illusion confessed that
he's been putting together right I would
be a little bit bummed if the elementals
in total aren't real they are real
within the comics
elementals are real characters and I'm
hoping they don't do some sort of
Mandarin situation right I'm not gonna
go into the whole Mandarin twist thingy
here whoa spoilers I just don't want it
to be a situation where like oh the
elementals actually aren't real
characters within the MCU they're just a
made-up thing that Mysterio has invented
I would like it if he's sort of
borrowing the lure of the elementals and
stuffing that these aren't the
definitive versions of the elementals
that he is presenting to us they were
talking about you know there's mythology
Thor is real they do exist still even
within the illusion construct that
Mysterio has put together - yeah okay
I'm gonna go one step further on the
theory then Mysterio made these on the
other earth as a ways of like lashing
out getting to spider-man then it went
too far then the snap happened
space-time opens up he gets sucked over
here and this is his second chance for a
little Marvel subversion so we're all
gonna sit there be like
this guy's messed up and then they're
gonna find out that he was villainous
but now he's trying to turn the new leaf
that's that's my weird theory for right
that's what I'm gonna go for that's
great so that's where I'm he's a scroll
and he's also got an infinity stone and
he was also hired by Aldrich Killian
yeah he was an iron man and the first
iron man if you look in the background
he's one of the kids I like that these
clips did at least do a smattering of
three distinct elements of the movie
it's like one is very school field trip
centric you know where they're in the
opera hall he's talking to MJ they've
got the thing with the opera glasses
yeah I really like you said playing a
peril of his balancing act between his
home life and his superhero life and
then we got like a really cool action
scene demonstrating just the effects and
some of you just though well that
actually looks great yeah it looks
amazing obviously it's a big blend of
CGI and whatnot but the whole thing
looks very realistic I like when they
would cut two shots and I feel like I
was like a universal back lot or
something like we're sliding in the
waters on him and he hits his back
against the wall like that was really
cool the way that transition
it's super fun cuz it because it is just
water and so you do get so many awesome
gags where yeah you can have perfect
continuity as you just splash back yeah
and then also you got that other element
of Peter Parker having to do spider-man
things without his costume
which yeah these are all you know Spider
Men isms yeah I appreciate that I to him
like Tony yeah totally early reactions
for most things are positive even for
films like ultimately come out with a
low cinema score low rods mean score I
thought the early reactions were so
specific on what was getting them so
excited and why they loved it so much
I'm more excited for this than I than I
ever was I've always been excited for
this now I'm like okay this is an
important film I've reached that
territory this is important totally and
hearing that about this being the true
end to you know the infinity saga or the
little coda on the end I think that is
really fitting because I flash back to
that to the weeping spider-man we had in
our end game screening it's like this
maybe is going to be this sort of like
we're gonna grieve it out with pain you
know and let's go together with Pete and
sort of live through that yeah
in sort of a cinematic way while having
some fun and getting some new characters
and steps well guys get your tickets
from far from home we are going July 2nd
late in the evening we'll probably have
a review up July 4th these take a while
at it anyway guys before we wrap this
video up I would like to give a page
from the day shot to a fairly new patron
of ours
Amy's been a patron for a while but he
recently pledged for the shout out tear
his name is Andrew Nickerson oh my I was
asking like where are you from in the
idea I is like this is the story about
how my pledge got flipped turned upside
down and like take a minute just sit
right there on your throne I'll tell you
how I became the $50.00 pledge of a town
called Bremerton Bremerton Washington
that's where he's from it's very popular
town people visit there constantly
everyone's always happy there but he was
saying that he was pledged to someone
with more money towards them first
mistake that you made Andrew always
start off doubling whatever you think
you want to pledge to us that's where
the best place to start and slowly
decrease it to one dollar one dollar at
a time over many many months many months
he was saying that we interact with him
more here than the guy did who he was
punchy with a higher amount so he took
that money put it towards our patreon
page Oh way to recognize what's up we
give TLC tender love and care
that's a Learning Channel suck in the
Dickerson of the Nickerson is what I'm
gonna be doing oh hey hey flicker send
that bickerson light it up cuz you're on
fire my friend yeah and I like this rap
quick erson rap quick erson rep at the
Nickerson quick erson this gun off the
rails
Andrew thanks for supporting us buddy
you're a great guy I think I'm gonna be
talking with you some more we'll find
out if you're great subscribers real
rejects click that notification bell hit
like buttons hit people who upset you
and we'll catch you guys soon